[Musica]
mi affascina sempre molto pensare che
martin shelf i nobel per la chimica nel
2008 stava dormendo quando lo hanno
chiamato per dirgli bravo è vito nobel
un altro stava al pub un altro l'hanno
fermato per strada o nobel bravo
e voi che cosa stavate facendo cinque
minuti prima che la vostra vita
cambiasse per sempre no perché io stavo
vendendo ciabatte ciabatte e scarpe per
andare a funghi nel 1994 un quotidiano
britannico pubblica un annuncio che fa
più o meno così 6 spregiudicata 6
esuberante ti piace ballare e cantare
rispondi a questo annuncio stiamo
aspettando te per formare la prossima
pop band ed è così cari signori che si
formarono le spice girls per la romania
ecco io di quella roba lì non ero niente
non ero sicuramente spregiudicata non
ero sicuramente esuberante antin
avevo appena vinto l'appellativo di
milagros milagros era una telenovela
argentina che andava molto di moda in
quel periodo questo per la mia grande
passione di vestirmi come una da mina
dell'ottocento
ecco voi capite quanto io possa essere
poco esuberante e poco spregiudicata ma
mia zia a natale mi aveva regalato un
registratore portatile un mangiacassette
rettangolare grigio con la maniglia che
fa clic nera e io giravo per casa col
mio vestitino col registratore sotto il
braccio ed era una bimba più felice del
mondo ma anche le spese che si andava
parecchio bene perché infatti nel 96 le
spice girls pubblicano buona b il loro
singolo di maggior successo e diventano
un fenomeno planetario e anch'io
decisamente me la cavavo parecchio bene
perché grazie al registratore di mia zia
avevo creato una trasmissione
radiofonica completamente inventata
direttamente dalla mia casa per la mia
cameretta trasmettevo questo funzionava
così c'è la musica quella che piaceva a
me c'era le storie c'era lo spazio
richieste le mie e c'era l'oroscopo solo
i segni che mi piacevano il mio myspace
che sfornano tre album un film qualche
disco di platino e anch'io
raggiungo l'olimpo grazie alla mia
trasmissione radiofonica inventata nella
mia cameretta perché grazie a quella
trasmissione io imparo tutte le canzoni
che passano per radio tutte soprattutto
quelle di una radio in particolare per
la quale io avevo nutrito un'ossessione
quasi maniacale trasmetteva 70
chilometri da casa mia in fm ovviamente
e io avevo un solo obiettivo nella vita
io dovevo arrivare a trasmettere in
quella radio non so come non so quando
ma io ci doveva arrivare purtroppo
sappiamo che la storia non va sempre
come si vorrebbe infatti anche le spice
girls
non è andata benissimo geri halliwell la
rossa ha deciso di lasciare la band e
nel giro di un anno
tutto quanto il gruppo si sfascia e
purtroppo si sfascia anche al mio
registratore perché mia mamma decide di
aprire la porta del bagno al buio
entrare e camminarci sopra lo prendo
come un segno del destino infatti le
spese cercano la loro strada anch'io
cerco la mia in modo un po confuso mi
scrive all'università sceneggiatura
perché mi sembrava la cosa più attinente
e trovo un fantastico lavoro nell'ambito
delle calzature
notate l'attinenza ho trovato quello
negozio di calzature che mi aveva
assunto
io ero la detta alle ciabatte ciabatte
per le donne scarpe per andare a funghi
per i mariti di quelli che si compravano
le ciabatte è un po lontano dal sogno
della radio è però mi ricordo un giorno
che la proprietaria se n'è andata
mi sono girata verso il termosifone dove
c'era la radiolina portatile che ho
cambiato stazione in quel momento sulla
mia radio preferita passa una spot che
promuoveva un corso per imparare usare
al mixer mixer importante per la radio
mi iscrivo al corso
vado al corso e scopro che a tenere il
corso sono proprio gli speaker della
radio e scopro che cercavano una voce
femminile e scopro che ne avrebbero
provinate 3 o eravamo quattro donne e 15
uomini
io avevo studiato 22 anni me lo potevo
sbagliare no fanno il primo nome fare il
secondo nome fanno il terzo nome
e io non avevo passato il provino non
chiedetemi perché non l'ho ancora capito
22 anni ho sbagliato provino torniamo
alle ciabatte
quello che però non sapevo era quello
che stava succedendo alle mie spalle
la prima era andato a fare il provino
l'aveva passato ma non le interessava la
seconda è andata a fare il provino la
passato mi è andata a lavorare nella
radio accanto la terza fatto il provino
la passato hai iniziato a trasmettere e
la sua famiglia si è trasferita dopo un
mese in inghilterra per sempre
io ovviamente queste cose non le sapevo
cioè la mia vita era finita mettetevi
nei miei panni io stavo lì signora 38 37
lei goretex ecco la mia vita era quella
lì e aveva un altro obiettivo eravamo a
luglio del 2006 che a tenere sveglia mia
nonna perché quella sera c'era la finale
dei mondiali di calcio
mia nonna era abbastanza anziana secondo
me sarebbe stato il suo ultimo mondiale
e mi sa che avevamo delle possibilità di
vincere taglia francia ce lo ricordiamo
tutti nonna stai sveglia insulti di
materazzi testata di zidane gol ai
rigori e io quindi stavo su un trattore
in mezzo a campania con la bottiglia di
lambrusco mi chiama la radio mi fa o
domani di presentare a fare il provino
io ci vado da perdere e io sono andata e
il provino l'ho neanche fatto io ho
cominciato trasmettere subito ero pronto
22 anni che mi preparavo ecco quell'anno
le spice girls si sono riformati e io ho
iniziato la mia carriera radiofonica col
programma che mi preparavo da 22 anni
musica spazio richieste e storie la mia
vita andava da dio
avevo il mio trasmissione in radio tutti
i giorni 3 ore e 5 giorni a settimana
aveva un appartamento avevo trovato un
fidanzato e poi si sa non come fatto
l'animo umano quando raggiungiamo un
sogno siamo nati per crearne uno ancora
più grande perché fortunatamente ai
sogni i tetti non li hanno ancora messi
e quindi
insieme al mio ragazzo abbiamo deciso di
fare qualcosa di nostro
di aprire uno studio di registrazione
quindi io decido di dare le dimissioni
dalla radio dopo sette anni e aprire uno
studio registrazione le cose vanno bene
agli inizi come tutti un po meno un po
male le cose iniziano a ingranare e il
mio ragazzo mi chiede di sposarlo
io mi sentivo come quando alle spice
girls è stato chiesto di aprire le
olimpiadi in the course tavoli nel punto
più alto della mia vita
purtroppo sappiamo che non sono bastate
le olimpiadi atene insieme le spice
girls come non è bastato il corso
prematrimoniale a tenere insieme noi due
infatti alla fine del corso materia più
prematrimoniale
abbiamo deciso che l'espresso che si
lasciano e anch'io mi lascio ritrovo
un'altra ragazza e io per l'ennesima
volta
rivedo tutta la mia vita consegnata in
mano a qualcun altro
a quel punto detto basta perché se io ho
fatto un percorso focalizzando la meta
facendo di tutto per arrivare lì è
ancora una volta non ce l'ho fatta ho
detto adesso basta
questa cosa non ha senso adesso io
voglio perdermi è l'unico modo per
perdermi per me era salire sui treni
io non lo so quanti treni ho preso per
un anno e mezzo
io so solo che l'unico mio obiettivo era
perdermi io salivo su un treno
dormivo su una panchina io non conto le
sale d'attesa in cui ho dormito il puzzo
delle sale d'attesa le panchine fredde
le stazioni dei treni in cui mi mettevo
le calze sulle mani perché congelato
l'asciugamano attorno ai piedi perché
magari freddo io volevo perdermi il
problema che tutte le volte che provavo
a perdermi e ad attraversare quelle
rotaie era il mondo che veniva da
attraversare me perché nella solitudine
di quelle panchine il mondo si sedeva
accanto a me mi raccontava la loro vita
le loro storie migranti paranti
business plan business woman bambini
guardie giurate chiunque si sedevano di
fianco a me mi raccontavano a me che
avevo l'unica storia che non potevo
raccontare a nessuno perché non aveva
senso e li ascoltava e una sera ho
chiuso il cerchio nella stessa camera
dove tutto era iniziato
mi sono trovata forse nel punto più
basso della mia vita davanti a linkedin
che è una cosa mostruosa di una
linearità pazzesca dove nella mia vita
di lineare non c'era più niente
come fai a scrivere su linkedin che tu
nel tuo curriculum ciabatte radio treni
su registrazione o io o master in
ciabatte e loro detto forse io non sono
quella cosa lì ho chiuso linkedin
io ho fatto l'unica cosa che sapevo fare
ho preso il microfono
l'ho attaccato e ha iniziato a
registrare ho raccontato la mia storia
ho raccontato quella delle persone che
si sono avvicinate a me che mi hanno
raccontato la loro e l'ho pubblicata in
rete
e io la mattina dopo avevo creato il mio
primo podcast e l'avevo creato in
ciabatte mettendoci dentro la
sceneggiatura lo studio registrazione la
radio la musica le storie e il mio
percorso finalmente si era unito
esattamente laddove era iniziato ma
soprattutto io avevo capito forse
l'insegnamento più grande della mia vita
che per tutto il tempo che io sono stata
focalizzata alla meta
mi sono dimenticata di innamorarmi del
percorso creduti innamorarmi del
percorso per poco lineare che era prassi
go go lato e sconvolto che era perché è
stato proprio quel percorso a portarmi
lì perché di percorsi lineari sono
solamente quelli delle piste delle
macchinine poi anche le macchinine
sbanda non ogni tanto deve accogliere
rimetterle a posto dei farle partire non
dovremmo stupirci i di vivere la nostra
vita come un racconto perché se ci hanno
sempre abituato alle grandi biografie
grandi nomi abituammo c alla normalità
abituiamo c alla vita vera alla vita
delle persone che hanno dei sogni che li
portano avanti con le difficoltà che la
vita mette in mezzo perché quelle
difficoltà mi hanno portato ad essere
quello che sono oggi quel podcast quel
giorno quella sera mi ha cambiato la
vita
il resto sono parte di un movimento che
conta 155 milioni di ascoltatori nel
mondo ad oggi di cui quasi quattordici
solo in italia 448 migliori di episodi
pubblicati online e quanta vita c'è in
quella roba è una maria 48 milioni di
storie che le persone buttano in rete
per farci sentire uniti per farci
sentire e capire che quel percorso che
abbiamo tanto odiato perché non ci ha
portato dove volevamo ci ha portato
invece nel posto giusto e nel momento
giusto
e quel posto giusto e nel momento giusto
per me adesso è nel mio studio a
raccontare nei podcast e le storie delle
persone e le aziende di chiunque mi
affido la propria vita e la propria
narrazione ma non lo faccio solo in
studio per onorare il mio percorso lo
faccio spesso e volentieri anche a casa
ma sempre con una grande umiltà e sempre
in ciabatte
grazie